hey this is a third video I would like
to talk to talk a little bit about
fanatics about sounds and preface that
sounds are there important points
they're important subject and topic to
talk about is their absolutely
fascinating you know I think that
personally think lemons are mainly sound
and then just secondly they're written
their script and they're this is kind of
a there's been a lot of fuss about this
in the sense that there's a lot of
people still think that the accent is
not important but you know everybody has
its entitled to their opinion we're in a
democracy here that and I just wanted to
share what I think about offending
anybody really this is not this is just
what I think personally but somebody
said that the essence accents when you
speak a foreign language is a matter of
that I say personally and very humbly
speaking that it is the first form of
respect that you show the language when
you learn it and to my own opinion who
we're producing well the accents it's
one of the most fascinating things
aspect of language learning I'm sure
that it happened to you to meet people
speak your own language with an
unpleasant accent and your natural
reaction is of the Chinese if not worse
other languages are like lanius in a way
and have to be treated with a lot of
respect attention if you decide to court
that lady try and do it well seeing a
foreigner butchering your language can
give you the same unpleasant feeling
seeing lady really care about your
sister your girlfriend being approached
by in an arrogant or rude way in this
regard I'm much more impressed by person
speaking three levels very well
rather than ten portly and I'm sure that
many of you agree with me I'm not at all
saying then one has to speak with a
native accent but I think that more or
less all of us all of us all can get to
a very good pronunciation with a proper
training we'll have a mouth and mash of
course and even as auto adults of we can
use it properly
the sooner we learn how to use our mouth
the better it is most of the people can
speak a number of languages very well
and with a variant with very good assets
have become have been learning speaking
and reading languages since the very
beginning the very beginning more or
less around 10 maybe around five six
it doesn't matter of seeing seeing than
your brain sounds you see sounds rather
than seeing sounds meat and not only
hearing them but understanding how to
produce it with your mouth for all those
who didn't have the chance to train
themselves one little don't spare it
because you can also do it the training
they'll come first this training the
specific training the open certain
simple words whatever what I want to say
is that even if we have filters in our
brain when we're off there's a filter
and our brain
Halford sometimes they see certain
sounds produced enough I would just but
if somebody tells you how to place your
mouth correctly then you can do it even
if you don't see that sound the phonetic
fabric of a language as I call it is a
flow of work linked together by a wet
specific for any given language which is
information the two main steps to speak
a language with a very good accent are
to get down the sound arrive in order to
reproduce single words decently and then
at the later stage or connect summation
the first step could theoretically be
done without the help of without help of
audio materials and there are books
showing how to place your tongue
properly but information can't be
learned from books the only way of
absorbent is absorbent if sleeve any
prejudice aside and listen attentively
to the specific sounds flow of the
target language as for the first step it
happens often that one isn't able to
reproduce some specific sounds in the
language it say the Swedish lonely be
the the feet foot and so on there are
two main parts when we use to reduce
sounds time DOM and lips you will notice
that there are sounds which change into
others by keeping your tongue and
certain position and just changing the
position of your lips you can find some
explanation as to how to produce some
sounds like the French but simply saying
and then rounding the lips is very easy
sampling advice like in this regard
IPA international phonetic alphabet
provides some interesting information
although talking through borders remain
of course an infallible attitude to get
out the sounds properly so this this is
the aspect of reproducing a single sound
that we all know that we cannot learn
the language perfectly there is no such
thing as learning eleven perkele and I
agree with that but we can learn to
master some aspects of language and
mastering we didn't just mastering
totally but we can master them in a way
and the lenders got a finite amount of
words of course but I find out what I'm
one to say that I've got a finite amount
of sounds in that language if you learn
a lot of variations but mainly if you
can you have those sounds you can start
by pronouncing simple words which make
up a fabric of liners single word very
well does the first step and I read it I
believe that everybody can do that with
proper training the most difficult
aspect of learning a language so of
learning out to the sound of language is
the in summation I think there is really
no guide for this but one useful thing
that you can try and do is to follow the
talker in mp3 for example experts talk
slowly at the beginning and this guy's
be Chloe you'll be able to follow in
sports better it sounds very useful
especially a beginning after stuff but
just do it always but I do the beginning
for Templars that mp3's whereas people
say go then go head and you say you
follow - I said in Swedish and you
follow it boys and then
one when you make per hours in the blood
week you start but you start adding your
pattern if this is the same philosophy
this shadowing thing for grammar and for
intonation
well that suggestion what if it you have
to try and speak as much as you can and
as soon as you can this affects
pronunciation to the brain mouth ear
system is the same thing people do we
have got a great ear of worth a you have
a right here you have refrain from sound
the brain is a filter when you grow up
we lose a part of our capacity of
picking up sounds unfortunately there
are some selves that we don't see
anymore
but this doesn't imply that you are not
able to you can't reproduce it if we are
made aware of our mistakes and told how
to say it the right way for example
making example I used to say women and
not women and I would have never seen
that mistake wouldn't never realized
that I was saying women the wrong way
unless my girlfriend of mine told me to
correct that sound I saw that when she
told me that there's a friend a
wonderful blood confessed to me that she
didn't see the difference between the
Frog
Act and the closed eight until I told
him to I told them about it I made him
see that as for me I didn't see the
difference between kite I used to say
for example kite [ __ ] and not tight
Chuck that until I thought that you need
which are two completely different
things speaking to yourself as to
herself or to foreign speakers how's the
sets emotional the brain of the brain
Mouse ear system towards the good
direction means that
it is true that if you talk to talk to
yourself or talk proper merit they say
you won't there's nobody to wreck you
but your brain is different just getting
there is getting the information so all
a matter of compasses Amit means that
you you are able to be much more fluent
and then when you talk to foreigners
they will correct your some mistakes you
here and there and you will get you more
proficient at least that's the way I did
so this is so there's another thing that
I forgot about caucuses and this I
didn't write it that way it's in Tommy
if there's branding line very different
level use I would call in this color and
he told me and I told him that I used to
do this when I was a little kid if you
want just to see ourselves better you
know that sounds physical way right and
spread you know the pressure that you
apply you to gear and you can put this
Cisco earphone and if you put your hand
in front of you the air which gets out
of your mouth guess back is reflective
it's the bounces on your hands and get
back your here you can even hear much
better much more clearly the sound here
of producing for you nothing to do this
is a anyway you try this and you were
here yourself much better than your
lighting this being over and over when
I'm speaking English maybe you put your
mouth here so that ear bounces and you
can hear and I told him hold you know
that I did this and I felt like I was
doing something weird he told me this
has got a scientific
relation for daddy's goals among yeah I
decide that was not in scientific
explain about our brother I a rather
cool so thank you so much and again I
will make some other videos pretty soon
chop